you want me to give you a huge secret
just you and me right now i'm actually
going to give you something remarkable
for real you ready
jess you're crazy bro i know dude i knew
i'm just giving you something
drock i hope you guys are filming this
[Applause]
you got your perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
about to go and give this talk a
conductor's uh annual event
a lot of sas companies do these events
where they bring your clients and want
to bring them value and that's kind of
what i want to do
i just want to go there and just bring
value this is not about vaynermedia
how do i bring the most value that's how
i do it with content that's how i do it
on stage
[Music]
one of the great reasons my company does
well is there's not a single person that
works at vaynermedia that
does the work more than i do as the ceo
of my company there's not one employee
that works for me that produces more
content deploys more ads
like i'm living in the trenches i'm a
practitioner
i'm in meetings sometimes with the
platforms where i'm correcting their
mistake of what their platform can do
you want to do good marketing make
things people want to read and watch
like like at its most basic form why do
i believe in three and four minute
videos
because when vayner's lucky enough to
make a great video like we did for
dwyane wade and budweiser everybody
[ __ ] watches it
and then you sell more budweiser it's
not super complicated
versus what's happening now which is
everybody's trying to [ __ ] hack
machines
bless you and the reason i acknowledge
that is i don't know how many people
here come from
eastern european russia but one of the
great superstitions
is when you say something and somebody
sneezes it's [ __ ] true
[Music]
so that was a really fun moment for me
because what i said prior to that is the
thing i believe in the most
people in here are pannering to machines
and reports
not to the end consumer let's make [ __ ]
that people want to watch
let's make [ __ ] that people want to read
let's make like if
we the marketing industry has to lean
way more into journalistic dna
and entertainment dna than into
marketing dna nobody here wants that
yes you mentioned shopify instagram yes
i've been trying to do this in this
person on the outside
yes do you think this market is dead no
amazon
no drop shipping uh drop shipping
no i don't think it's dead i prefer
you start a product and sell it yourself
but if you want to drop ship
it's not dead it's more competitive it'd
be like saying is seo debt it's not dead
it's just not as good as it was four
years ago because it's supply and demand
and
competition but if you're good at it
it's remarkably
effective yeah oh yeah thank you bro
thank you so much i'm just starting i
have my youtube channel
i'm just having trouble like producing
new content
all the time i would doc i would i would
highly recommend documenting versus
creating
okay when you get into ruts yeah just do
a day in the life
or just something but like when i do
vlog type of content yeah my channel my
views are
going a lot more down because then what
then like if i'm doing stuff on because
i have an audience of programmers
yes so when i'm doing stuff with coding
content or something
those get a little bit more views but
but you're pandering to views instead of
putting out content
that's true if you're not inspired to do
[ __ ] coding content you're not gonna
put out anything that day
right i'd rather you film yourself
drinking a cup of coffee and maybe
talking about
the story of why you started coding in
the first place
that's true yeah because you know what
the problem big problem i'm having is
that i'm kind of
i don't feel like really coding that
much anymore because i'm focusing on
running the business yeah
talk about that i'm not really related
to the audience when i first started
doing
business videos instead of wine videos
my my views collapsed because my
audience was blind people
yeah but then i just built it back up
[Music]
you can't live your life predicated on
how many views the video is gonna get on
youtube
right so i'm just trying okay so yeah
that's that's important for me to
understand
it's the biggest important thing for
content producers to understand
everybody's getting caught up in likes
and subscribers right instead of
actually living their [ __ ] life
well okay so here's the thing i also
have um
you know in my mind i'm running a
business as well so i'm trying to get
the so it's not just likes and
subscribers i'm trying to cultivate a
community of developers who are then
also purchasing our products well then
bring them then you got to bring them
value
right then every single thing that you
should be putting out has nothing to do
with likes
or subscribers it should be like what in
the world is going to help this
developer
and you have to make that content with
the expectation of them
never buying your product right then
you'll grow
yeah that's true i know you know how
many people i've changed their lives and
made them millions of dollars and still
haven't bought a sneaker or a bottle of
wine for me
and it doesn't bother me one bit
understand
right yeah thanks i appreciate that take
care
[Music]
how old are you
yes i saw that you got yo i'm 96 years
old you got time
it's true ethereum unless you drop dead
that second you do have time
hey hey rug off do we have virginia's
phone number
do we have our phone number uh yeah i
think i could probably
find it great can you uh
can you uh text it to me yeah if i can
find
are you gonna like call her or something
is that what you're trying to do
no i'm gonna get it from you and just
leave it in my phone
i'll finally cool thanks brother
yesterday and i'm sure the clip will
play right now well you guys can edit
however you want but i would probably
start with the call
and that little exchange and now as i
say this then play that exchange if you
quit tomorrow i'll make you promise if
you quit tomorrow
i will personally never do this i will
personally heavily shout out your
business
on social to get you 50 clients you
would have never had i will too but you
can
quit tomorrow and you have to prove it
to me and now come back here
yesterday i had a great call with a
wonderful woman from pennsylvania
virginia
and she promised me that she would quit
her job today
i genuinely believe that this is the
best decision of her life
for happiness and i also secretly know
that if for some reason
she does quit and then the economy fails
or something disastrous happens that i
will feel so much guilt
that i will personally make sure that i
de-risk all the risk of her doing this
so uh i'm gonna try to call her right
now
and um and make sure that she has
in fact quit which she probably at 11 14
in the morning east coast time
hasn't yet um probably thinking about
doing it at the end of the day
or maybe she wanted to just get it over
with
or she's not planning on doing it at all
what she doesn't know is that i'm
focused on it
she's not gonna be able to duck me all
day no voicemail just keep trying
you have reached virginia houser of
greyhound
all right not victoria
let me tell you what i'm actually doing
in public as garyvee
everybody in the world right now on the
internet
and in life is spending all their time
saying you know if the vp level
was reminded a little bit more or and
what i'm doing as an svp and what i'm
giving
you advice to do is just do it
what i'm doing is just doing i'm not
jumping into social and debating people
who have different points of view with
me trying to convince them what they
should do
i'm just executing my output
of practical positivity and letting that
create the collateral impact that i want
i have a funny feeling
that if you just disproportionately do
and
promote doing that
over time you'll affect a lot more
people
you know i really believe that i'm
hoping
that this incredible age of judgment of
others
leads to accountability and actions
because people are going gonna find out
very quickly over the next five to ten
years
that yelling at somebody else to change
their mind to their
way is going to have 0.0 results
the way you get somebody to do something
whether that's to buy a sneaker
or to act nicer to each other is through
communication
i want to build the greatest machine
in the form of a company with all sorts
of weird disciplines like publishing
and a speaking bureau and all sorts of
things
to be the best in the universe in
communicating things
to get people to do things and some of
those things will be very selfish like
buying an american football team
and some of those things will be very
noble like curing my brother's crohn's
disease
or helping claude become the president
of the united states of america
i love this pressure i really do because
i think i'm good at it
and i think i want to pay back the
universe for
you know what it gave me you know i
think i'm good at it
i know i know the intent is in a hell of
a lot better places
than the alternative alpha capitalist
that could do it and so like right
life's about alternatives who else can
build billion dollar companies from
scratch like me
and who is she and he as a human i'm a
rare version of it
and so i need to see that through and
document it so that i can inspire
people who think doing good is going to
africa
which is absolutely good there's another
way
build an incredible company that
everybody aspires do you know what's
going on in silicon valley
when steve jobs was at his height young
dudes thought they had to be dicks like
steve
do you know how excited claude can tell
you better do you know what we're doing
here
i'm inspiring a totally different alpha
executive
female and male that's huge
that's legacy that's cool like what like
you could be an alpha assassin winner
and have a heart as your logo what
that you know it may seem to you might
be too close to it but it's super cool
super different and it's go see it
thank you i listen to marcus more than
you i love you guys see ya
that that's why i love you know listen
this is you know actions over words
i'm very much a good guy and want to
like do a lot of nice things and i'm
also
want to buy the new york jets like you
can have
you can be you know and i think that's
where people are getting caught they
feel like you either have to be
an alpha businessman and kill everybody
ruthless and terrible
or you need to be a hippie and i'm like
why can't you do both like
why can't you succeed by being good and
being a good person and being a good
operator
and successful it's kind of like how i
think about athletes athletes are
allowed
to be really tough on the field trip you
and rugged
that you know and then when the game's
over it how's your family
share jerseys but business people that's
how i think about it when i'm making
business decisions
i've gotta you know i've gotta win
[Music]
i've been dying to ask you this question
um so
i'm in social media influencer based in
south africa right
still in high school working my ass off
doing things i can do to get my content
there out as much as possible right
yes and one of the questions i was dying
to ask you
is that how do i take it to the next
level i've been collaborating
with all of these brands i've been
keeping on putting out content
but i want my content better but even
though i'm still in high school
i still have to attend school still have
to attend class i still have to do all
that type of stuff
how do i keep on doing this and taking
it to a higher level bro
you want me to give you a huge secret
just you and me right now
i'm actually going to give you something
remarkable for real you ready
put it up start making content
that you know won't do well on instagram
and youtube
[Music]
that won't do well that won't do well
why because number one mistake that
everybody is making right now in the
entire world
is they're trying to take their content
to the next level
and they think that means more likes and
more followers
and i think the next level is more truth
and more experimenting
definitely just you crazy bro i know
dude i knew i'm just giving you
something
drock i hope you guys are filming this
[Music]
oh i'm so sorry jesus christ not this
not this event everything i got you just
i was thinking about everything
in uh this is jason putting on his
seatbelt
because avi told him to i'm like that's
that's the best moment of the wear your
seat belts kids all right
um in the front in new york look
i thought i had 74 luca rookies
in the safe lou what's the safe password
don't say it out loud
not for the camera do you want to
explain why there's a safe shape
the [ __ ] was that i'm not going to
remember that
we could change it uh this is my safe
i'm wearing more shelves five
jackie robinson rookie cards those are
jackie robinson rookie cards but
going americana on it hot dogs and
burgers
on the grill two o'clock you know a
little
you know corn hole a little wiffle ball
jason you see where i'm going with this
hot dogs
burgers there's just something funny
about bringing jason into the
conversation you see where i'm going
jason
uh
hello